I got a call from my good friend York
Newman the head of Microsoft flight
simulator he told me about this once in
a lifetime out of this world opportunity
so I'm here in Budapest the capital of
Hungary York he's around here somewhere
let's go find him New York Hey Paris
it's great to see you great to see you
thanks for coming to Budapest of course
what am I doing here I'll tell you on
the way we have a vote to catch a boat
yep we don't have a plane nope come on
Paris
thank you
George what is this place what kind of
aircraft are you storing in here ah dude
it's much cooler than that
all right Paris are you ready for this
you know I'm ready for this all right
let's go
welcome to the world of Doom this is
incredible
come on I want you to meet someone
hey how's it going how are you man it's
good to see you see you Paris I would
like to introduce Patrice Vermette
Academy award-winning production
designer of Dune it is very nice to meet
you I'm a huge fan of Dune now Patrice
can you tell me what is this place well
this is the warehouse where we actually
keep most of the props and the setback
elements that we used on doing part one
and part two
you know York how did all this get
started so it goes back to November 2021
Dune had just hit the movie theaters
worldwide and we got a car from
legendary and they had the idea that we
bring an ornasopter into Microsoft
flight simulator
and me being a lifelong science fiction
reader and fan a big huge fan of the
Frank Herbert books how could I say no
okay now it makes sense after seeing the
trailer at the Xbox showcase I
understand why you brought me here you
guys want to take a look because we
actually do have a couple of
ornithopters here if you want to see you
want to take a look that would be
awesome yeah let's do it all right let's
do it all right
look at this
it's a one-on-one wheel size don't want
to stop that it's amazing sure thank you
the knee likes things to be plausible so
that's why they were built to look
military rugged
and stealth now here's the most
important question were they built to
fly
you mentioned because I've been asked
that question a couple of occasions uh
no they don't fly they are heavy they're
11 tons so York you have to get this
working in the game how did you do this
in Flight soon yeah it was actually
interesting so in in general onasoptos
can fly and do fly this particular one
given that it weighs 11 tons that's
going to be a little bit harder
specifically because it's not really
doing the owners of the bird flap it
does oscillation of the blades and we
currently don't have the material
science to get the thrust and the lift
but on the Rockers I think this is
absolutely possible that flight Sim we
made it work
Patrice we're here
can we go in absolutely all right let's
do it normally we'd go in through the uh
climbing up the landing gear but guess
we'll do
yeah so what's cool about this Paris is
that all those buttons are actually
realistically hooked up to the system
Master engine switch what you're doing
there above those the red are basically
all the lights and as you notice
um it's all analog because in the world
of Doom there's no thinking machines
thinking machines have been illegal for
10 000 years that was actually
fascinating when we implemented it we
because it's a science fiction we
thought oh it's glass cockpits
everything is going to be computerized
like none of it is this is a very
practical helicopter almost like from
the 1960s so York in the first movie the
popular was able to do a lot of cool
moves and Maneuvers you're going to be
able to reproduce that in Flight Tim oh
yeah totally I mean the really cool
design that you guys came up with is
each blade is independently controlled
so each blade has its own lift and
thrust and that means you can go from a
really stable hover to a steep dive and
back to a Glide instantaneously I would
just say thank you that you designed
such an awesome and realistic machine
because that's what we do we bring
realistic machines to life but if you to
see a little bit more about the game
design I have something for you
absolutely I'd love to see
all right so the setup for this
expansion is that you are a tradies
pilot on a raucus flying in order
here is what we build
we basically build this section of a
ruckus here's the capital city of Arkin
here's a Botanical Garden we have that
as well and the first thing we do is we
train you up the first take off fast
landing and then the Deep dive and then
we take you to some of the extreme
locations like above the cliff the hole
in the rock
the red Chasm you really have to show
your pilot skills and then towards the
end then there's a secret mission which
I can't talk about today but that
basically wraps up the experience it's
gonna be great super exciting hey it was
great to see you again
Paris
thank you for thank you so much for
having me
York
where to next
well I don't know what they eat on the
Rockets but this is Budapest and I hear
they have excellent goulash I know a
place let's go